a strasbourg les 12 de la communauté ne
renonce pas poursuivre leur unification
politique et monétaire est dans le même
temps ils disent oui à
l'autodétermination et à la
réunification éventuelle des deux
allemagnes deux ans de révolte des
pierres dans les territoires occupés un
anniversaire qui n'annonce rien de
vraiment nouveau
un revenu minimum pour les étudiants qui
connaissent des difficultés financières
c'est l'initiative d'un maire de la côte
d'or pour rétablir une certaine égalité
devant les études en art ou l'un des
pères de la peinture abstraite vient de
mourir à l'âge de 85 ans à antibes c'est
en france qu'il avait trouvé refuge
après avoir fui l'allemagne et n'est ce
pas là monsieur bonsoir
l'histoire va tellement tellement vite
en ce moment qu'on a parfois envie de
l'arrêté un instant pour mieux
l'apprécier d'autant qu'elle a lieu
cette fois-ci à nos portes à berlin et
de l'autre côté de ce qui était hier
encore le bloc de l'est ce qui se passe
en ce moment n'est pas abstrait cette
histoire qui s'écrit n'est pas réservé
aux hommes politiques aux grands de ce
monde elle est écrite par les peuples
on peut la toucher du doigt c'est ce
qu'ont voulu faire une quarantaine de
collégiens de la région de besançon qui
avec leurs professeurs se sont rendus à
berne reporter valérie fournis ou roger
moore
l'innocence face à l'est qui sifflent 43
enfants
propulsé dans l'histoire immédiate pour
une fabuleuse leçon d'histoire
alors vous savez que le promu berne a
signé durant la guerre 47 c'est le début
de la guerre froide alors cette guerre
froide le jury revient sur la
chronologie elle va durer dix ont
horreur berlin et pour l'allemagne je
trouve 61-61 vous savez ça la date
d'édification donc perçu mieux ils vont
nous toucher le frapper on chercher les
meilleurs morceaux seront alors connus
inlassablement pour garder des bribes de
ce pan d'histoire venue d'une période
qui n'ont pas vécu la guerre froide est
libre et c'est tout à fait impensable
rester dans notre village lors qu'il se
passait quelque chose de formidable ici
vous avez laissé comprendre
le lundi que lundi après les événements
je suis arrivé en salle des profs et
j'avais tellement été bouleversé par ce
qui se passait je vois mon collègue j
mais qu'est ce que tu fais là tu
déranges greta berlin
je crois que c'est possible j'écoute en
effet être à berne voir en fin de mur de
la honte
regardez les vocaux et prendre
conscience de ce que peut être la
liberté qu'on ne l'a pas savoir que
beaucoup se bat pour l orgasme
penser qu'il allait se produire là des
gens qui voulaient absolument pas c'est
qu'ils ne franchissent pas
l'action ici ils ont voulu métro témoins
jusqu'au bout visiter berlin est
compliqué de vivre de l'histoire qui se
joue maintenant
de l'autre côté mais le car qui les
transportent est interdit de séjour
là-bas from their hne
alors il essaie de passer à piles mais
là c'est le froid ils attendent qu'il
refoule trop de monde
la visite se poursuit à l'ouest toujours
avec étonnement l'impression de liberté
des gens autour du mur
comme s'il y avait bien eu par concéder
tout
comme si le regard des hommes avaient
jugé l'histoire les impressions que l'on
s'empresse d'écrire pour son histoire à
soi
oui depuis cette visite l'histoire a
continué sa marche en avant à l'est en
tchécoslovaquie le deuxième gouvernement
de la semaine sera connue demain
dimanche il comportera au moins une
moitié de non communiste que ce qui
donnera peut-être satisfaction à la
population et dès ce soir le chef de
l'état depuis 1968 monsieur gustave ou
sac a annoncé qu'il était prêt à des
missions en allemagne de l'est qui vit
actuellement sans état et sans chef de
l'état le parti communiste s'apprête à
changer de nom et il a placé à sa tête
un jeune homme de 41 ans philippe roche
il y à des camarades très compétent ici
qui n'ont même pas été délégué
expliquez-nous pourquoi ce fut le
congrès de la transparence où chacun a
pu dire ce qu'il avait sur le coeur et
pour la première fois nous avons pu
filmer ces débats on attend des bergues
offert le maire de dresde comme nouveau
chef du parti s'est finalement ghisi
avocat de 40 ans ennemi juré des ricoh
necker qui a été élu par les 2700
délégués
il conduira le changement au sein d'un
parti qui va jusqu'à perdre son identité
en même temps que ces structures
stalinienne les communistes est
allemands ont surtout voulu montrer
qu'ils étaient encore bien vivant m je
suis venu de karl marx stadt nous sommes
toujours très près là bas des
préoccupations des ouvriers nous sentons
qu'ils attendent de nous des choses
précises et on ne s'est jamais éloigné
du parti alors bon taureau bambou
étonnant de voir que l'armée a son mot à
dire dans la direction du parti
surtout à l'heure où les militaires sont
montrés du doigt dans la rue comme force
potentielle de répression ce congrès
c'est la dernière et unique chance qu'il
nous reste pour garder un parti et pour
sauver le socialisme dans notre
république
17 heures de débats et de votes mais le
congrès du parti reprend samedi prochain
à l'ordre du jour les relations avec les
autres partis qui se partagent le
pouvoir en rda
les bouleversements à l'est ne sont pas
sans conséquence à l'ouest évidemment et
l'on pouvait penser que le sommet
européen de strasbourg allaitent en
subir les conséquences et bien
finalement le bloc de l'ouest comme on
peut désormais la plaie a tenu les chefs
de l'état de la communauté ont maintenus
et confirmés leur programme
d'intégration politique et monétaire
mais ils se sont également ouverts à
l'est reconnaissant sous conditions aux
allemands le droit à l'autodétermination
et à une éventuelle réunification
georges bortoli yves barbe en
accueillant ce matin le chancelier kohl
à la résidence du préfet du bas rhin
monsieur mitterrand sacrifié au rite
obligatoire des petits déjeuners franco
allemand un parent sommet mais cette
fois ci en plus on respirait les
relations franco allemandes qui avaient
semblé un moment compromise repartait du
bon pied dans un sommet que monsieur
mitterrand estime à des plus importants
de l'histoire communautaire rarement
un conseil européen étaient saisis donc
de problèmes aussi graves aussi
déterminant est aussi difficile que ce
qui se propose à nous et comme il a été
apporté un certain nombre de réponses
sur le plan intérieur de la communauté
de réponse très importante la charte
sociale qui va sur remplir peu à peu en
raison du nombre de mesures prévues par
la commission et la convocation de la
conférence intergouvernementale du pôle
sur l'union économique et monétaire ce
sont deux les sillons considérable au
cours de cette conférence de presse une
autre constatation s'ébauche l'europe ne
coupait en deux partagé par les deux
grands l'europe de yalta c'est fini on
peut vraiment non pas spécialement à
partir d'aujourd'hui mais notamment
aujourd'hui on peut dire que yalta
commence entré dans l'histoire ou plutôt
rentrer dans l'histoire qu'on raconte
mieux assortir de l'histoire présente à
la désintégration à l'est doit répondre
l'intégration à l'ouest dans la
communauté européenne
voilà au fond la philosophie de ce
sommet de strasbourg renom pour les
faits le commentaire maintenant philippe
sassier c'est peut-être parce que à
strasbourg le chancelier kohl a dû
constater que malgré une grosse botte
c'est à dire un arc fort qu'il ne
pouvait pas prétendre porter seul la
culotte politique en europe que le
couple franco allemand s'est ressoudé et
que l'europe vient de franchir un
nouveau pas en bien sûr on est encore
loin
l'objectif final une économique et
monétaire encore plus de l'union
politique et à strasbourg les douze ont
montré qu'ils pouvaient parler d'une
seule voix sur des problèmes graves
la coopération avec l est et la
réunification allemande et on a reconnu
ici que la coopération avec les laisse
devaient aller de pair avec la
construction européenne on craignait une
panne de l'europe monétaire en fait une
décision à 11 permet de convoquer avant
1990 une conférence intergouvernementale
pour parler de la monnaie unique
jamais maggie thatcher n'était aussi
isolé pourquoi eh bien peut-être que
pour la première fois à strasbourg on a
senti que derrière l'europe économique
commençait à se décider
une europe
à retenir tout de même que tout le monde
n'est pas enthousiasmé en allemagne même
à l'idée d'une réunification ou d'une
confédération ainsi pour la première
fois cet après-midi à berlin ouest
plusieurs milliers de berlinois ont
manifesté compte
il s'agissait essentiellement des
écologistes mais aussi du puissant
syndicat ouest allemands dgb
il considère qu'une éventuelle
réunification serait en fait une
annexion de la république d'allemagne de
l'est par la r être demain une
manifestation similaire aura lieu cette
fois-ci à l'est de l'autre côté du mur
l'actualité de ce samedi c'est aussi un
minuscule archipel de l'océan indien
proche de la réunion les comores depuis
une semaine là bas un mercenaire
français bob dénard a pris le pouvoir
après avoir éliminé le chef de l'état
qu'il avait d'ailleurs lui-même
contribué à mettre en place il ya de
cela quelques années des troupes
françaises ont été amenés à la réunion
mais pour l'instant le ministère de la
défense dément une intervention
éventuelle laurent bousses il alors
qu'au ministère de la défense on
affirmait ce matin que la france n'avait
pas l'intention d'intervenir
militairement aux comores les renforts
en armes et en matériel arrivé
aujourd'hui dans l'océan indien
appartenaient tous à des troupes d'élite
de l'armée française spécialisée dans
les actions commando et l'infiltration
en territoire ennemi grâce aux avions
hercules et transall qui les ont convoyé
ses troupes stationnées maintenant à la
réunion et à mayotte pourrait tout à
fait servir un coup de main sur l'île de
grande comore où sont stationnés bob
dénard et ses hommes mais s'il attaque
n'a pas lieu
ce déploiement de force devrait quand
même faire pression sur les mercenaires
et les obliger à quitter les comores à
marseille et à paris un millier de
comoriens résidant en france ont
manifesté à l'appel de l'opposition
comorienne pour réclamer le départ des
mercenaires et la mise en place à moroni
d'un gouvernement provisoire de large
union nationale
un événement technique et politique de
taille qui peut bouleverser l'équilibré
des forces au proche orient est
intervenu cette semaine en voici la
preuve par l'image l'irak vient
d'expédier sa première fusée capable de
mettre en orbite des satellites civils
bien évidemment mais aussi militaire
jacques vieille ce n'est peut-être pas
une ariane une atlas ou une fusée très
sophistiqué mais ça y ressemble
voici donc les images de ce qu'il faut
bien considérer comme un événement
majeur
l'irak vient de réussir le lancement
d'une fusée à trois étages 25 mètres de
haut très pointu 70 tonnes de poussée
l'équivalent d'un des quatre moteurs du
premier étage d'ariane de quoi lancer
des satellites mais aussi des charges
militaires une porte et
vraisemblablement de plus de 2000
kilomètres alors une question qui à
aider l'irak sans beaucoup de
renseignements on se livre au petit jeu
des suppositions
les spécialistes rappellent que l'irak
participe avec l'egypte au développement
d'un missile argentin le condor 2 qui
pourraient bien être les deux étages à
poudre auquel les irakiens auraient
ajouté un premier étage dérivé d'un
missile soviétique à propulsion liquide
qu'ils avaient déjà perfectionner
pendant la guerre avec l'iran l'iraq
puissance spatiale
on ne sait rien de la base de lancement
même pas où elle se trouve sur les
images
aucun technicien bien des questions qui
peuvent inquiéter israël mais aussi bon
nombre de pays arabes surprises
techniques donc événements politiques
que ce lancement pour monsieur arafat le
leader palestinien il s'agit là d'un
cadeau fait à la révolte dans les
territoires occupés par israël révolte
des pierres dont c'est aujourd'hui le
deuxième anniversaire comptabilité
macabre deux ans d'harcèlement ont
provoqué la mort d'au moins 650
palestiniens dix neuf israéliens 37
mille blessés palestiniens 2000 blessés
israéliens
patricia constants
ce qu'on appelle en arabe les shebab les
adolescents ont réussi à organiser ce
petit défilé aujourd'hui pour commémorer
le début de la troisième année de leur
soulèvement
ce sera une des rares manifestations de
la journée l'armée israélienne en nombre
ayant imposé un couvre feu quasi
générale sur les territoires occupés les
pierres comme depuis deux ans les gamins
poursuivre inlassablement leur cap
d'usure contre des soldats israéliens
qui ne joue pas au même jeu grenades
lacrymogènes dans un premier temps pour
les disperser puis pire à bâle
aujourd'hui dans le village de beni naim
en cisjordanie il y a eu deux morts le
bilan général de ces deux années de
soulèvements et de plus de 600 morts
côté palestinien et d'une vingtaine côté
israélien une guerre d'usure dont on ne
voit pas la fin
yasser arafat aujourd'hui à bagdad vient
de déclarer personne ne nous forcera à
arrêter malgré les pressions oui dans ce
combat quotidien depuis deux ans les
points de vue de part et d'autre évolué
on s'en aperçoit lorsqu'on s'intéresse
au sort de ceux qui ont été blessés dans
cette bataille qu'il soit israélien ou
palestinien
charles enderlin
fayez mahmoud à bousbecque a été blessé
le 9 septembre dernier à rafah dans la
bande de gaza au cours d'un incident
comme celui-ci refusant de déblayer hier
barrages de pierres et s'est battu avec
les soldats l'un d'entre eux a tiré
touché à la moelle épinière fayez
souffre d'une paralysie partielle des
membres inférieurs il a 32 ans marié
hier six enfants
dieu seul sait de quoi mes enfants vont
vivre à présent lui seul peut nous aider
comment considérez vous la lutte des
palestiniens aujourd'hui ce que fait
l'intifada la manière dont les jeunes
palestiniens affronte israël est une
source de fierté pour notre peuple
la paix est elle possible entre vous et
les israéliens
les israéliens ne veulent pas la paix il
nous accuse d'être des terroristes mais
ce sont eux les terroristes et pire
encore la coexistence entre israël et
les palestiniens est impossible dans la
situation actuelle
fays qui a été opéré dans un hôpital
israélien suit un traitement à l'hôpital
palestiniens moka cède de jérusalem est
il espère retrouver usage d'une jambe
dany cohen lui c'est qu'il restera
paralysé
c'était en mars 1988 soldats dans une
unité d'élite
il patrouillait dans la vieille ville de
naplouse
cette pierre de 30 kg a été lancée d'un
toit une brisant la colonne vertébrale
après huit mois d'hôpital il a eu le
temps d'oublier sa colère avec sa
chienne daisy il habite un petit
appartement à tel-aviv n'a d'abord une
solution oui qu'il faut négocier avec
l'ol paie je ne sais pas s'il faut qu'on
parle qu'on réunisse une conférence de
paix pariez vous avec des palestiniens
lorsque vous étiez en uniforme avec les
jeunes n'ont ils s'enfuyaient mais
lorsque nous devions rentrer dans une
maison il y avait toujours un vieux ou
une vieille qui nous demandaient
pourquoi on répandait nous obéissons aux
ordres si j'avais eu le choix je ne
serais pas allé là bas
pas à cause de ma blessure mais parce
qu'il faut les laisser si vous deviez
rencontré un palestinien paralysé comme
tout ce que j'aurais à lui dire c'est
que c'est dommage nous représentons
chacun ses leaders à sa façon mais en
fin de compte la même chose que disent
vos parents au début ils ont pris très
mal ce qui m'est arrivé mais il faut
vivre comme on dit dany n'a pas encore
décidé s'il va reprendre ses études ou
chercher du travail
ils rêvent de passer un brevet spéciale
de pilotes d'avions légers au liban pour
la première fois la radio officielle
syrienne damas déclare qu'il est temps
de mettre fin à la situation actuelle
c'est-à-dire à la résistance du général
chrétien aoun et le président assad
affirme dans une interview que son armée
est prête à mettre fin à ce qu'il
appelle une rébellion contre le pouvoir
du président élu du liban
monsieur avérous tout l'entourage du
cheikh fadlallah annonce qu'une
tentative d'attentât a été déjoué contre
le leader religieux chiite proche de
l'iran il faut le savoir
cent kilos d'explosifs dissimulés dans
une voiture au tour à paris cet après
midi dans la cour d'honneur des
invalides le gouvernement français a
honoré pour la première fois des hommes
qui s'étaient engagés aux côtés de notre
pays dans les événements d'algérie
neuf anciens combattants musulmans
harkis ont été décorés après avoir été
pendant 27 années le plus souvent
ignorée jacques violet michel de base
ils étaient neuf cet après midi dans la
cour d'honneur des invalides
adjudant-chef sergent soldat a requis à
recevoir la légion d'honneur ou la
médaille militaire
9 au nom de tous ces combattants
musulmans engagés aux côtés de la france
pendant la guerre d'algérie
au cours de cette prise d'armes le
gouvernement français leur rendait un
hommage officiel 27 ans après je pense
que cette reconnaissance qu'en témoigne
aux harkis on aurait pu le faire
beaucoup plus une reconnaissance que
certains algériens immigrés en france
aujourd'hui conteste et considère comme
une réhabilitation
il n'y a pas de réhabilitation il ya des
gens qui étaient français qui ont
combattu avec l'armée française et
auquel on rend hommage comme en hommage
à tous les soldats dans les françaises
harki mot race ni pendant toute la
guerre d'algérie ces unités supplétives
été recrutés et employés dans les mêmes
conditions que l'armée française en 1962
après les accords d'evian
soixante mille d'entre eux désarmé et
rendu à la vie civile
arrivé en france dans des conditions
souvent extrêmement difficile en même
temps que les pieds noirs
il existe en france des responsables
politiques qui prennent des initiatives
ainsi le maire socialiste de chenôve en
côte-d'or monsieur roland carraz propose
aux étudiants de sa ville dont les
familles connaissent difficultés
financières un rm un revenu minimum de
l'étudiant qui peut aller de 2800 francs
à dix mille francs par an selon les cas
une manière en quelque sorte de rétablir
l équilibre devant les études reporter
serge me serait pire laurent constants
brigitte à 20 ans étudie pour être
professeur d'anglais
pour l'instant elle vit dans une hlm de
la banlieue de dijon à chenôve chez ses
parents leurs ressources sont modestes
bruno et nasa ses amis sont dans le même
cas ils sont étudiants en sciences éco
grâce au ra me le revenu minimum
étudiant il faut peut-être y voir un peu
plus clair
j'ai fait des petits boulots on en
arrive à ça à faire du baby-sitting
à un moment je travaillais dans des
centres de loisirs comme animatrice
c'est comme ça que je me débrouille
puisque je n'ai pas trouver des petits
boulots je ne peux pas donner de cours
pour le moment j'ai finalement trouvé
moins exigeants en fait une saison lui
toutes ces heures employés donc à gagner
de l'argent pour pouvoir faire des
situations correctes et ben sont les
ordres m'ont dit que je ne travaillais
pas donc à ce moment là on peut arriver
effectivement avec la jonction avec le
rythme qui lui permettra de passer moins
de temps à chercher de l'argent et ce
temps là je veux pouvoir me consacrer à
mes études
le rmi c'est une allocation calculé en
fonction des ressources de l'étudiant et
de sa famille
il peut varier de 300 à 3000 francs par
mois pour l'obtenir il faut bien sûr
habiter chez nous car c'est pour
l'instant une initiative de son maire
que je souhaitais faire ici à chez nous
c'est apporter des compléments de
ressources et pour des jeunes gens des
jeunes filles qui auraient eu de très
graves difficultés à rentrer à
l'université et dont certains auraient
pu peut-être rentrer mais dans de
mauvaises conditions c'est-à-dire dans
des disciplines mains des filières pour
lesquelles n'étaient pas faits un jeune
homme environ 200 jeunes vont bénéficier
du rmi
il aide matérielle bien sûr mais aussi
un soutien psychologique
là où la pauvreté peut être ressenti
comme un complexe d'infériorité
ce pas pour autant que je me sens
diminué par rapport à des gens qui vont
qui ont eu la chance d'avoir des parents
relations objectives 2 millions
d'étudiants l'an 2000 pour y parvenir il
faudra sans doute un large appui social
c'est pourquoi le ministère d'éducation
suit l'expérience du rmi avec beaucoup
d'attention la politique maintenant la
politique française avec cette
proposition de jacques chirac et du rpr
de demander aux français d'utiliser leur
droit de pétition auprès du président de
l'assemblée nationale et par conséquent
du président de la république pour
obtenir et qu'un référendum soit
organisé sur le droit de vote des
étrangers dans les élections locales
municipales donc principalement pour sa
part monsieur jacques chirac est contre
cette participation et puis cette
manifestation ce matin à toulouse du
front national 8000 personnes en vie
autour de madame stirbois la nouvelle et
seul député lepéniste à l'assemblée
nationale il s'agissait également pour
les organisateurs de faire le pendant au
concert de clôture de la tournée
sosracisme organisée sur le thème de
l'intégration et des moyens nécessaires
à sa réalisation
en bref encore à la prison de lannemezan
une enquête administrative a été ouverte
après que le ministère de la justice ait
reconnu que le projet d'évasion de neuf
détenus dont deux seulement ont été
retrouvés jusqu'à présent était bel et
bien connu par les responsables de
l'établissement pénitence et puis le
petit tarik ce jeune garçon d'origine
turque de 10 ans disparu il ya plus
d'une semaine maintenant dans la région
de bourganeuf dans la creuse a été
retrouvé malheureusement mort découvert
par un chasseur on ne connaît pas encore
l es conditions dans lesquelles l'enfant
a été tué arrêtons-nous maintenant à
l'instant sur un un souvenir celui du
paquebot france pour faire mentir michel
sardou qui avait intitulé une de ses
chansons ne m'appelez plus jamais france
est bien pour le temps d'une croisière
le norway a été rebaptisé de son nom
d'origine croisière pèlerinage préparé
dans les moindres détails jusqu'à la
porcelaine de limoges gérard dalmaz
andré sort
roi des palaces flottants de 61 à 74 le
france était notre ambassadeur de luxe
hélas trop cette majesté ne pouvait
rouillé au quai de l'oubli rentabiliser
rebaptisé norway et l'a repris la mer
mais comme les norvégiens respecte les
beaux bateaux le nom de france vient de
ressusciter pour dix jours
la cérémonie qui faisait picoter
certains yeux se passait à miami au
départ d'une croisière française
musicales et culinaires avec l'équipe de
france de gastronomie 30 fois chef
poussé solistes de la toque limoges
capitale de la baisse elle a mis les
petits plats dans les grands
21 porcelainier et le meilleur imprimeur
sur céramique pour ce logo spécial ont
offert leur travail
exemple la maison raynaud qui depuis
1849 fournit les grands de ce monde de
l'elysée à des scènes afghane
défi et marathon en quinze jours
fabrication de 13 mille pièces à 150
francs chacune voilà un bien beau cadeau
à la mesure du voyage gourmand de la
croisière france mille huit cents
convives 40 repas donc la porcelaine de
limoges c'est parfois tout casser à
commencer par son image un peu
vieillotte
les fabricants de porcelaine de limoges
ont une capacité de production qui à la
limite était sous-estimé
quelquefois on a en a peut-être cru que
n'est pas pouvoir faire face à cette
opération et nous avons quand même gagné
la bataille
la guerre du feu avec trois cuissons
dont la dernière qui vitrifie le logo en
oxyde natural une assiette doit ouvrir
l'appétit
mais encore fallait-il la garnir
noblement sur le france là encore pas de
fausses notes exemple les huîtres en âge
glace et de guy savoy une des étoiles du
firmament des casseroles en bagage
accompagné il est parti avec 12000
marraine pendant que le maître
andrew est emballé un gigantesque
plateau de fromages une tonne 2 en fait
guy savoy cette croisière français la
palette de nos talents non vitrine
française a dit qu'il sommes à dix mille
kilomètres de la france et c'est assez
impressionnant lorsqu'on connaît tous
les problèmes que l'on a pour un pour
exporter des produits comestibles aux
états unis qui se voit était donc de la
famille des 33 star des fourneaux et
cela n'a pas été de la tarte de la
réunir de taguer à robuchon en passant
par 3 go et à berlin
la rétine
retrouvailles entre cordon bleu et un
vieux ruban bleu ce monument de la mer
ce monument de notre sous denis à
restons dans ce domaine avec la
disparition à l'âge de 85 ans de l'un
des pères de la peinture abstraite hans
hartung réfugié en france après avoir
fui l'allemagne nazie il s'engagea dans
la légion étrangère voilà pour sa vie
d'homme
quant à sa carrière de peintre elle eu
pour théâtre sa maison d'antibes
véronique ghiglione le se disait
l'ennemi du style il voulait innover
toujours ne jamais se laisser enfermer
le toujours aimé ce papier est loin de
ce que le pêcheur il utilise le geste
tant aux courbes tantôt droit le
pistolet à peinture pour caresser la
toile le ballet où le rameau d'olivier
pour la fouetter il aimait les tons
stridents et acide et allez les bleus
durée les jaunes solaires sont des
toiles monumentales hans hartung était
née à lake city il y à 85 ans en 1935 le
nazisme l'avait obligé à fuir
il s'était réfugié à paris 46 suit
l'année de sa découverte les années 50
marquèrent le début d'un grand succès il
était le père du tachisme cette façon de
peindre par éléments colorés et mêlée il
devint le chef de file de l'action
painting américain lui qui voulait agir
sur la toile il resta et restera
toujours un grand maître de la peinture
abstraite parmi les quinze peintres les
plus chers de notre époque son
engagement pendant la guerre lui avait
coûté une de ses jambes
mais dans son fauteuil roulant il
continué à peindre le bonheur
il préparait une exposition à la
physique pour l'hiver prochain dans
cette allemagne de l'est qu'ils
n'avaient pas revus depuis un demi
siècle
en sarthe où aura à peine eu le temps de
sentir renaître sa ville avant de s'en
aller
une autre triste nouvelle le décès de
bruno carette 33 ans bruno carette
n'était pas tellement connu sous son nom
mais le groupe comique auquel il
appartenait et connu ce sud celui là
puisqu'il s'agit des nuls bruno carette
âgé de 33 ans donc est mort d'une
maladie très rare la
leucoencéphalopathie ce dut donc à cette
maladie qu'il avait 33 le tiercé pour
terminer voici les chevaux qu'il fallait
jouer cet après midi pour gagner 425
france et l'ordre du tiercé 5 20 12 pour
ce qui concerne le kart est pucé bien
ajouter simplement le 17
voilà ce journal est terminée tout de
suite après des prévisions météo
avec josé dans la pierre ensuite le
téléthon qui reprend jusqu'à un peu plus
de minuit et ensuite à la fin de nos
programmes vous retrouverez philippe
gassot pour les toutes dernières
informations je souhaite une excellente
soirée je vous donne rendez-vous à
demain 13h je vous dis bonsoir